ever wonder just what kind of weird
stuff is buried in the Netflix catalog
you could spend all day scrolling around
in search of the strange but we've got
you covered let's take a look at some of
the most bizarre films you can find on
Netflix wetlands based on the novel by
Charlotte Roche this movie features
unrealistically massive amounts of
bodily fluids to tell the Starke true
and riveting story of an 18 year old
woman coming of age while exploring the
human body and an act of rebellion
against her mother she finds herself
trying to rekindle a love between her
divorced parents while falling for her
male nurse a man she met after a shaving
accident gone terribly wrong hard to be
a god the Guardian called hard to be a
god a monumental and monumentally mad
film based on the novel of the same name
by Arkadiy and boris strugatsky it's set
in what looks like a medieval sci-fi
Russia but on a different planet that
looks remarkably like Earth they're two
competing factions called blacks and
Gray's or at war the peasants are
disfigured ugly and stuck in copious
amounts of blood and mud for eternity
the film forces its audience to ponder
another world like ours where life is
and it has been much worse upstream
color this is a movie about a parasite
that passes between humans Diggs and
orchid surprisingly that's not the
weirdest thing about it a man known as
the thief manages to implant-- a worm in
a woman called Chris that allows her to
mentally communicate with pigs which
also allows her to come to grips with
their very dysfunctional relationship
with her boyfriend Jeff it prompted
slate critic force Whitman to write I
just saw upstream color what just
happened a question we're still trying
to answer God of cookery this film about
the rise fall and rise again of a
Chinese chef tickles your funny bone
while playing to a very specific
audience variety describes it as an
entertaining often very funny blend of
high-energy Cantonese comedy in culinary
kung-fu but if you're not a fan of both
cooking and martial arts don't worry
because it's hilarious and daring enough
for any movie lover to enjoy 3 Headed
Shark Attack if you looked at the title
of this movie and thought it screamed
for actor Danny Trejo then you're in
luck you'll find him in a fishing boat
full of guns and ammo beheading a
three-headed shark the plot is
straightforward enough the mutant
creature in the title attacks a ship and
it won't stop until it's eaten everyone
while the passengers use anything they
can to fight it
up what's not to love
it's like jaws plus two Moorhead and
also terrible but in the very best way
now one could possibly top that what
about a movie called the ABCs of death
what have you hired 26 directors one for
each letter of the alphabet then what
have you tasked each of them with
crafting their short film that needed
only to fall into a certain runtime and
follow a narrative built around death
that's exactly what producers ant Thomas
and Tim League did with this
experimental anthology film watch it for
the cinematography and for some
seriously boundary-pushing but jokes he
never died the tagline - he never died
gets right to the point it's hard to
live when you can't die
actor singer author and bicycle short
enthusiast Henry Rollins plays Jack
jacks the kind of mysterious antihero
who was listless drifter middle-ages
offended when his teenage daughter is
kidnapped
Rollins plays Jack as a subtle homage to
Arnold Schwarzenegger Terminator which
is probably the least weird thing about
the film how we're just going to go kill
another roomful of people you are
probably come on demonium unless it's
coming from guillermo del toro a little
bit of fantasy horror goes a long way
where del Toro enthralled audiences with
Pan's Labyrinth
argentinian director Pablo Perez
demonium opts to go full-out weird at
the expense of plot pacing and character
development that's cool though because
instead demonium delivers a bizarre mix
of demons wizards and martial arts
action that ports with your eyes like a
splash of drain cleaner just about every
10 minutes Timonium goes from bad to
badass the bad acid and back again
an endless carousel completely
unfettered by logic just sit back and
enjoy the ride the scribbler what if you
were a killer and didn't know it that's
the question asked by the scribbler
which follows a woman named Sookie with
multiple personalities living in an
apartment building sanctioned for
psychiatric patients talking in
metaphors
we need to figure out what they need how
crazy are you one by one the women in
the building start dying allegedly
jumping to their deaths the movie is
told within the framework of Sookie's
interrogation by the police after the
fact giving it a weird sense of altered
chronology and an unreliable narrative
after all it's a story being told by a
crazy woman so yeah it gets way weird as
the story progresses superpowers and
sanity a totally freaky god machine all
hidden behind the closed doors of a
Psychiatric Institute it boasts some
pretty sleek visuals and a unique
storyline if nothing else Knight watched
a watch before he made his
english-language debut with 2008 wanted
or his follow-up 2012's Abraham Lincoln
vampire hunter timur bekmambetov wrote
and directed a double feature of Night
Watch and day watch these two sci-fi
films simply don't follow any of the
norms of Hollywood blockbusters and
that's a good thing probably the
dreamlike dissonance of these movies is
enough to make you question your own
sanity since the only constant rule in
the day-night watch universe is make it
shiny all the plot threads about
alternate dimension and vampires and
ancient forces do come together in a
sort of coherent story but it's a hard
weave to figure out good luck
death chasm once upon a time someone
watched Scott Pilgrim vs. the world and
thought this would be a lot better with
more heavy metal and naked women and
maybe someone like beats up a demon with
a sex toy it's a thought we've all had
at some point you're having that thought
right now admit it anyway whatever cost
is to happen death chasm is now an
irretrievable piece of the world it's
out there unable to be undone so what is
the film supposedly about well it
follows for teenagers who start a metal
band in their garage and inadvertently
play a song that unleashes hell on their
quiet suburban neighborhoods to save the
town they have to pretty much kill
everybody in it New Zealand's been
giving us some great quirky comedies
lately like what we do in the shadows
and death chasm is certainly part of the
gang even if it's the weird kid that
hangs out in the back acting like a spaz
zombeavers a movie called zombeavers
featuring singer John Mayer and comedian
Bill burr should get your attention it
see that deer up there dancing I don't
think you do
especially when the plot follows the
fallout from a toxic waste bill that
sends a swamp full of zombie beavers to
attack a gang of helpless teenagers
according to roger ebert calm zombeavers
is exactly what it sounds like a STONER
friendly horror comedy about undead
beavers finally truth in advertising
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you love to
[Music]